so we're still kind of opening i mean is
the way we look at it we're getting more
restaurants open and more food options
open and
um and there's a few things we still
have to work on to be quite honest
[Music]
he's a pretty good three-point shooter
he likes the corners though
this guy's a pretty good three-point
shooter
he's excited about it too
[Applause]
switched out onto him he's got him
jumping around he's behind the back
just drives by and then steps through
smith jr
crafty how hard he plays how much he
moves the fitness level it's crazy this
is crazy stop it
he gets in these curry flurries
that's where defense is really like oh
you know then you throw in porter v lisa
all the shooters they got and then he
get dollo's like draymond another
[Applause]
it's the little movement before the
split action cut off him jordan pull
catches a piece of cj mccullum makes him
have to trail steph
from behind obviously
you add lillard mccollum norman powell
then coming to nurkic you're starting
solid
curry
he's a flamethrower just stopped
[Applause]
[Applause]
unbelievable watch him just kind of jog
up there and then just explode
off the little handoff
he's just running around